pour d'accord j'étais un petit peu
cachottier je vous ai caché un projet
sur lequel je bosse depuis l'année
dernière maintenant je vous en parle
cet été sur la chaîne youtube je sors
une série audio qui s'appelle l'épopée
temporel voilà c'est dit un fait que ça
sorte un moment voir c'est quoi une
série audio alors une série audio c'est
comme regarder une série mais en fermant
les yeux le ballon dans l'épopée
temporel vous allez entendre des
personnages incarnés par des comédiens
de doublage bruitages et théréau de la
musique composée spécialement pour
l'occasion mais c'est surtout des
personnages marrant qui vont vivre une
aventure incroyable du suspense des
méchants bref une grande aventure pour
vous cet été sur la chaîne youtube
toutes les semaines ces dix épisodes de
8 minutes environ qui raconte l'histoire
de trois personnages thomas un jeune
loser que j'incarne iris une fille qui
vient du futur et elliot un robot et ils
vont traverser le temps à la recherche
d'un grand scientifique les personnages
vont visiter plein d'époque l'egypte
antique la civilisation maya ils vont
même aller en allemagne pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale ils vont croiser
les nazis je vous en dis pas plus no
spoil
j'ai écrit l'histoire avec naveau
françois descraques et yacine belhousse
avait une histoire un peu folle et l'ont
rendu encore plus dingue
l'enregistrement c'était mortel avec les
manuels curtil qui fait jim carrey ils
sont que g h i après mon nom patrick
bord qui fait son goku adultes brigitte
le cordier qui fait son goku enfants
nous acceptons votre les faits et
véronique augereau qui fait marcher
mason ses mannequins ou votre cape town
c'est quoi ce entre égaux des comédiens
super que j'adore jeumont fait des
personnages totalement barré et je suis
super content de ça j'ai hâte que vous
entendiez cappuccino
combien de suivre le célébrissime
pirates je vends place pour l'anecdote
j'avais déjà fait des sketches audio en
2007 avec mon pote jérémy ça s'appelait
les tripes à deux balles c'est à udine
on salue la nhtsa a ouais ça va être
ouais ouais j'ai perdu mes parents j'ai
fait une fausse couche mais sinon ça du
coup de fer l'épopée temporel c'est un
petit peu un retour aux sources pour moi
revenir à
des trucs je faisais avant de me lancer
sur youtube et en bonus pour agrémenter
la série audio vous allez découvrir
pendant chaque épisode des dessins faits
par des illustrateurs différents qui
vont interpréter des passages de
l'histoire ils vont interpréter même les
personnages dont vous allez voir par
exemple un personnage qui va voir sa
tête là et juste après l'heure à cette
tête là c'est comme la couverture d'un
livre elle est là mais c'est pas
important c'est l'histoire libre cours à
son imagination
le premier épisode sort le jeudi 13
juillet à 17h sur ma chaîne youtube et
ensuite ce sera tous les jeudis à la
même heure sur ma chaîne comme je suis
très sympathique
un petit extrait 4
[Musique]
je le sens dit si tu te demandent
sûrement ce que tu es en train d'écouter
chers auditeurs tu vas découvrir une
aventure débordante de rebondissements
et de sauts dans le temps amp ap ap ap
ap c'est tout pas pas plus à nan mais
faut pas abuser des bonnes choses de
façon si vous voulez découvrir la suite
c'est très simple c'est le jeudi 13
juillet à 17h sur ma chaîne youtube pour
le début de l'épopée temporel à écouter
avec des écouteurs avec un casque avec
une enceinte au bord de la plage sur
votre smartphone tout seul avec des amis
c'est comme vous voulez soyez au
rendez-vous et pour ne rien louper vous
pouvez cliquer sur la petite cloche
comme ça vous êtes sûrs de recevoir la
notification si vous êtes abonnés si
vous n'êtes pas déjà abonnés eh bien il
faut cliquer ici
comme ça vous êtes sûr de voir tous les
épisodes et les poupées temporel
j'attends que vous cliquez sur les trucs
je reste là une heure ou deux mais tu
cliques apparaît sur le téléphone c'est
un peu moi je suis un pauvre sur des
fonds
[Musique]